Hello, and welcome to this new lessons. In this lesson you will learn how your
programs can make decisions. Let's look at an example. Here you have a typical
elevator panel, and yes elevators are controlled by computers these days. And
if you look at the buttons, you will notice that there are buttons for 10, 11,
12 and then goes on with 14. so, there's no button for 13. and that's of course
because, many people are superstitious and don't want to be in the 13th floor
of a building. Now, contrary to popular belief, the 13th floor is not filled
with secret government offices. There actually is a 13th floor, they just call
it the 14th. So, the software that controls the elevator car needs to adjust
for this human foible. Here's how you can do that in Java. Let's say floor is
the number as provided by the user, 10, 11, 12, 14, 15, 16 or whatever, and now
we want to compute that actual floor. Then we need to make a decision. In Java
you use the if statement to make decisions, and you enclose the condition in
parenthesis. Then you use a pair of braces, and inside you put the statement or
statements that you want to have executed when this condition is true. So, if
the floor is greater than 13, then we want it to adjust by subtracting 1. On
the other hand, if the condition is false, then we'll carry out the actions in
the else part of this statement. In which case, the actual floor number equals
the floor number without any adjustment. And that's all there is to it. Let's
go over the important parts again. The keyword if starts out the conditional
statement. The condition goes in here, and is surrounded by parentheses. If the
condition is true, then the part following the if is executed. And if the
condition is false, then the part after the else clause is executed. Alright,
now it's your turn. In some Asian countries, it's not the number 13 that brings
bad luck, but the number 14. And those elevators wouldn't have a number 14. And
in fact, just to play it safe, some property owners eliminate both the 13 and
14. So, go ahead and modify the program in the next exercise so that it
translates the user selected number to the actual floor number. And know, there
are no hidden floors with secret government offices.